stuart rochester co-author of honorbound
american prisoners of war in southeast
asia someone buys your book won it again
well they get a 700 page book that is
both a I think a a novel or II a
narrative of the experience of the
prisoners of war in the in Southeast
Asia and they also get an analysis a
documented analysis of what that
experience was like and how well the
POWs performed
not according to memoir renditions but
according to records according to do
briefings and reports and a good deal of
research material that we went through
over a period of almost 10 years so it's
both a I think a fascinating story as
well as a comprehensive scholarly
analysis and record of the performance
of the POWs and their experience as well
as to some extent getting into the
problem the MIS but mainly the POWs
issue where do you work I work at the
Pentagon I'm in the history office and
the office of Secretary of Defense which
is a small office of about three
full-time professional historians and we
do history such as this although
normally not this type of history more
often a history of the administrative
history of the work and the policies of
the Secretary of Defense and we also
have an archival function and we do
papers and analyses for the secretaries
and for other officials in the building
as a way of getting into some of the
many stories you tell about torture in
here I want to read Air Force captain
Conrad Troutman 1967 an interview he
gave after the homecoming did he give it
to you oh no Troutman's
the quote from Troutman probably was in
an after-action report that we had
received although Troutman was
interviewed by my co-author Fred Kiley
who knows who knew Troutman personally
Troutman was one of the seniors and one
of the senior ranking officers at the
zoo one of the camps that was located
about three miles southwest of Hanoi and
the passage that you're referring to is
one in which I think traveling is a good
summary of the of the torture experience
particularly the rope torture in which
he describes how they were literally
strung with they're strung up from the
ceiling with their arms kind of behind
her back and cinched up to the point
where their arms on where they almost
their shoulders were almost dislocated
in some cases that would be and they
would be put through this periodically
in two or three sessions and it was one
of the worst of the tortures some were
maimed in the process few got through it
without giving up some information
without in some ways giving the enemy
what he wanted how many prisoners of war
were there during the Vietnam War
altogether about eight hundred there
were eight hundred at least documented
cases of POWs are a number of
discrepancy cases we were not sure if a
guy was perhaps captured for for a few
hours and escaped he may have been held
just very briefly caught in an ambush
and got away immediately some of those
or cannon on certain lists but basically
about eight hundred altogether
let me read captain Conrad Troutman 1967
let me try to tell you what it really
feels like when they tightly bind your
wrists and elbows behind your back with
nylon straps then take the strap and
pull the arms up up your back
to the back of your head if you can
remember when you were a little boy the
fooling around you did and someone grabs
your hand and just twist your arm up to
your back and says say uncle he does it
with just one hand and this as you
remember is a very severe pain well
imagine this with both arms tied tight
together elbow to elbow wrist to wrist
and then using the leverage of his feet
planted between your shoulder blades
with both hands he pulls with all his
might till your arms are up and back
over your head forcing your head down
between your feet where your legs are
between iron bars the pain is literally
beyond description
one more little point here besides the
pain itself you are tied up so tight
that your windpipe becomes pinched and
you breathe in gasps you're trying to
gulp in air because your wind passage is
being shrunken your throat in a matter
of 30 seconds becomes completely dry
after about 10 or 15 minutes in this
position tied up so tightly your nerves
and your arms are pinched off and then
your whole upper torso becomes numb it's
a relief feel no more pain the breathing
is still difficult but the pain is gone
you've been anesthetized however when
they release the ropes the procedure
works completely in Reverse it's almost
like double jeopardy you go through the
same pain coming out of the ropes as you
did going in right they all describe it
very similarly the double jeopardy
aspect the coming out of it you
experience the same thing as we're going
in it
Fred Kylie the co-author actually went
through a version of that at Fort
Belvoir at their survival school here in
the Washington area I declined to do it
but Fred I had heard so much about the
rope torture that just to get the feel
of it as he said actually underwent
underwent it and had very much the same
sensation that that Troutman describes
by all accounts it was the worst of the
many kinds of torture that they were
were subjected to but curiously some
managed to get through the as with all
things with the POWs what some found to
be the worst case others found to be
more tolerable and there were some who
found other tortures to be
more dishes and more difficult to
tolerate how many do you think went
through the Rope torture on between 1960
so called middle years which were the
most difficult ones when the torture
program was fairly regularly practiced
to extract information and also for
punishment purposes most of the POWs had
at least one session in in the ropes and
later on as you get toward the end of
the the captivity period closer to
homecoming fewer and fewer them would be
subjected to the the rope torture but
there were many others bud day who is
who won the Congressional Medal of Honor
and who was as tough and not as anyone
over there at stuff a resistor and had
as much fortitude and strength as anyone
bud day had the most problem with what
was called a kneeling torture really
would simply have to kneel for long
periods of time often on a pebble or a
stone and as he said in his memoir try
that sometime
for for four or five hours and see what
it feels like they had more problems
with that than with the ropes we spent a
little bit of this picture this was not
by day it was AB Alvarez where is this
picture and who was he Alvarez versus
famous as the so called old man of the
north
he was the first pilot captured over
North Vietnam in August of 1964 so
Alvarez would have been there almost a
decade altogether he came out of 1973 at
this point I think was probably around
1966 or 67 Alvarez is being taken
through through the town they often
would take prisoners
through one kind of a tour of either
bomb bombed out sites as part of the
indoctrination process they would take
prisoners quote out on the town
many of the POWs actually welcomed as
as at least a change of pace from the
monotony of being in their cell for all
but 20 22 hours a day but algorithm net
and that photo shot is out on a a one of
those I think tours around the city let
me ask you about people we know of
because they've been in the public
spotlight since then
Jeremiah Denton was a senator from
Alabama for a while right Denton was one
of the top ranking seniors he was
captured early in the war in I believe
1965 Denton had a reputation even among
the seniors as being one of the
strictest and one of the staunchest in
terms of his adherence to the code of
conduct and requiring that the others
adhere to it and every now and then
Denton will get into some conflicts with
Stockdale and Guarino and some of the
others had a slightly different
interpretation of the code but Denton
was one of the toughest resistors he was
certainly one of the most admired POWs
he's the one who gives the first one off
the first senior off the aircraft at
homecoming and gives the address on the
tarmac at Clark Air Base where he says
god Bless America and what did he what
did he had to do with the tapping code
Denton's contribution is so-called tap
code the tap code was a system whereby
that POWs communicated and and Denton
contributed an important new nuance or
aspect and so called vocal tap code
whereby prisoners would be able to
communicate not just by a tapping on the
wall but through coughing were sneezing
and which was very important because it
was very easy to disguise that form of
communication in a climate an
environment in which everyone had either
some form of malaria or some kind of
coughing some kind of lung disease from
the chilled winter or the dampness
and so these places sounded like
tuberculosis wards anyway the various
compounds but they were often coughing
in a certain code that Denton had had
developed there is a current Federal
Trade Commissioner by the name of Orson
swindle who used to run the Ross Perot
campaign at one point right always his
roll swindle was another one who was
would be considered a hardliner he was a
marine they're not as many Marines who
were captured as naval aviators of
course or Air Force Airmen but swindle
was one of the more prominent POWs in
this middle period underwent a good deal
of torture he's one of those who was a
master of what's called the [ __ ] you
look that he would give the Vietnamese
he took absolutely no quarter from their
guards he would be again we use he'd
have to read I think it's one of the
toughest resistors and of course when he
came out became active in politics and
eventually in the Perot campaign
congressman Sam Johnson of Texas yeah
Johnson another one you're you're going
through but or considered many of the
toughest POWs most courageous and ones
who were able to withstand torture and
interrogation as well as anyone Johnson
was a Air Force major and one of those
who ended up at Alcatraz Alcatraz was
considered the place where the worst
offenders the worst resistors were put
there were 11 of them were placed in
Alcatraz altogether same Johnson would
have been one
to get a ticket to Alcatraz you had to
be a difficult prisoner at a strong
resistor current ambassador from the
United States to Vietnam Pete Peterson
former congressman um interestingly
Peterson does not play a prominent part
in the book we don't mention him to any
large extent and for some reason you
don't get a lot of reading on him in the
after-action reports but in interviews
we know that Peterson was very much
respected and admired by Sam Johnson and
by the other tough resistors so he too
had a very strong record although he's
not he's one of those who's not
mentioned nearly as prominently as Sam
Johnson or swindle or some of the others
he mentioned in the book former vice
presidential candidate on the Ross Perot
ticket James Stockdale
well Stockdale by all accounts I think
even when compared with Denton and the
other leaders probably the most
respected of the do W is Congressional
Medal of Honor winner who was willing to
slash his wrists and kill himself before
giving information on the communication
system at voilá at the Hilton and in
this particular compound called Vegas at
the Hilton
Stockdale who also was very important in
terms of developing a version of the
code of conduct of rendering of it an
interpretation of it that would be
conveyed and communicated throughout the
whole prison system that was considered
a reasonable commonsensical approach to
how much torture they would be that the
men the POWs could be expected to take
attitudes about you know do you have to
escape you have to try to escape even if
it means risking your life and the lives
of others how long is the code well the
code of conduct of course which is what
what
stocke tails and for that matter others
other leader other senior leaders
instructions were based on is is rather
short code of conduct based on the it
came after the korean experience the
basic concept was stick to the stick to
the the big four your name your rank
serial number date of birth
Stockdale developed something was a
system called he used the acronym back
us which dealt with some of the main
experiences that the POWs would face and
Hallie should should deal with those
experiences the be stood for Belle don't
bow at least not in public in any kind
of a televised public display where the
Vietnamese North Vietnamese would be
trying to show the Americans to be upset
we as and some this in a submitted as in
a submissive pose the a stood for air
don't go on the air don't tape don't go
on the radio at least draw your utmost
not to take towards your up to a certain
point if you can no longer withstand it
without feeling you were losing a limb
or your life gives something but give
something that would not be significant
certainly don't betray any comrades
don't betray the organization's system
in the prisons with a communication
system the C stood for crime and it's
Bacchus acronym don't admit to any
crimes
the the K stood for kiss which was don't
kiss the ring if they offer you early
release if they appear to be magnanimous
and are trying to pose as you main in
lenient don't don't thank them for that
and the important toss the unity over
self which is the basis of the whole
system and I should say that Stockdale
was not the only one who contributed to
this code Denton contributed as well at
certain points Stockdale would be out of
commission
Devon were Robinson risen er would be
the the senior in a particular situation
at a certain time and they'd also
developed certain incremental additions
to this code of conduct as to what was
expected of other prisoners and at the
end I should mention John Flynn who was
the top ranking senior Air Force colonel
who was very important toward a later
point in the captivity in kind of
consolidating this guidance and this
code of behavior in the back you have a
chart that shows that there were 4100
POWs in World War one 130,000 in World
War two 7100 Korea 771 in Vietnam 23 in
the Persian Gulf
how were the prisoners of war in Vietnam
treated compared to those other words
right well in terms of the treatment we
make the point that we don't get into a
lot of comparison but we do make the
point in the beginning where we try to
put this in context that no wars have
been hospitable to the prisoners of war
and in some cases the Korean treatment
was and even during World War two was as
brutal were more brutal than what was
experienced by the prisoners in Vietnam
however I think what was really
significant here is the longevity this
is these guys were the longest held POWs
in American history so they were this
was over a decade or were during the
course of a decade for some who were
beautimous almost a decade Alvarez Floyd
Thompson Jim Thompson and the South
called the old man in the south it was
captured in 64 and who came out in 73
these were guys who POWs it underwent
repeated instances of torture and of
course just having to withstand some
very difficult conditions in terms of
the climate in terms of sanitation and
hygiene
malnutrition over a period of time so
certainly they have to rank right up
there with the guys who survived the
worst abuses and in particular the most
difficult conditions over a long period
of time I counted in the back of
Appendix 215 prisons in North Vietnam if
I've got them and maybe off one or two
how many were there in some people in
South Vietnam there were not so many
prisons as simply locations often jungle
stockades these the your captivity in
the South was more of an itinerant
nomadic kind of captivity we're often
just one or two prisoners and a cluster
later one war would be brought brought
together but during much of the the
period of captivity in the south
you do not have formal enclosed prison
structures as such as much as you had a
camps that would be moved every few days
and stockades would be set up with with
the cages and we make the point in the
book I think one of the real
contributions of the book is that we
discuss not only the the stories of the
the pilots at the Hanoi Hilton but the
experience of these many cases lower
ranking enlisted men Marines and army
enlisted that were captured in the south
and who had to go endure this itinerant
captivity isn't discussed in any other
books to our knowledge and in many cases
had ahead in some ways a lonelier
certainly but also a more challenging
experience because they had to deal more
with the elements being outdoors in
often in the jungle or mountainous
jungle location where there would be
leeches and scorpions and snakes and
having to deal with probably a more
precarious food and water situation as
well so the guys in the south also with
withstood the ones who survived it
Mendes adversity as well as the better
known cases of the Denton's and the
stock dales in the north who was dieter
Dengler and what's his story
dengler was a naval aviator who was
captured I believe in 65 somewhere in
the fairly Omegan v in 64 I think 65
probably in Laos and dengler is an
interesting case because a rare view
very few POWs who got out Laos alive
even at the end of the war at homecoming
only 9 v OWS came out of out of out of
Laos me out of a total number or out of
a total number well we don't know see
the big question about M IAS and the big
mystery about how many wherever in the
prison system really is in the case of
Laos we just don't know because they
were held singly in very isolated cases
they would be a one or two would be held
in a cave and we know a lot of guys went
down in good parachutes when there are
at least 300 cases where guys were
downed and Liao's appeared to be in a
position to survive and to become
prisoner but we only know of nine that
that came out in 1973 and several who
escaped including Dengler along the way
dengler is had a phenomenal story and
it's told in a book that he's written
it's so phenomenal a lot of the analysts
who reviewed it were not sure of its
accuracy and he partly because Dengler
had been so dehydrated and may have been
hallucinating and was not sure himself
and exactly what he experienced in any
case he did manage to get out he managed
to escape along with several others who
were in this one group he was the only
one
doing Martin was an army helicopter
pilot who joined Dengler in this escape
and we know that Martin died along the
way when they encountered some I believe
was villagers with machetes and Martin
was killed along the way very
interesting case and would remains a
discrepancy case is the case of Jean
Debruyne who went out with Dengler and
who has never been his body has ever
been recovered we don't know what
happened to him we just know that he
didn't make it out there were reports
along the way that Debruyne would be
spotted in a certain sites or an Aryan
loss but he did not come out of 1973 and
he was one of the remaining really
intriguing discrepancy cases the Bruns
brother Jerome Debruyne is a professor
at the University of Toledo who has made
it his life's work to the remainder of
his life to try to find give more
information on Debruyne but we don't
know what happened Debruyne didn't make
it out but dengler did and just
apparently as he was he was on a
mountaintop and had just about run out
of food he was eating frogs he was
eating leaves and finally he was spotted
by a rescue aircraft and thinking out
how many people did you talk to for this
book we talked to over a hundred of the
POWs as well as many analysts with the
Defense Intelligence Agency we talked
with a family of POWs including some who
did not come back and also one
interesting case the brother of al Bruno
who was one of two commits suicide al
brother killed himself
after coming back very tragic case one
of the great heroes of the resistance
and a fine person who was unable to
adapt to a broken marriage
some difficulty a tree came back so we
talked to family members we talked to
many of the POWs my co-author Fred Kiley
did most of the interviews and I should
say that Kiley is is I believe the
foremost authority in this country on
u.s. POWs Fred did most of the research
for the work and has encyclopedic
knowledge based on his interviews with
the prisoners as well as his review of
the other literature how did you divide
your responsibilities for Fred did most
of the research in fact over a period of
almost 10 years when we started this
project I came along later in the game
after Fred had actually started the
project Fred had gotten sidetracked by
some other responsibilities in the
National Defense University where he had
heads up there headed up there
publication program and the research
program I picked up the book from Fred
Fred had drafted a number of chapters
have done this massive research and I
did a good deal of the writing of the
later chapters and worked with Fred to
fend to complete the drafts of the early
chapters what do you say to someone
listening who says this man works for
the Defense Department were getting the
Pentagon version of the POWs well we
hear that from time to time and all I
can say is that there was absolutely no
there were no constraints and no
inhibitions on us at all aside from the
normal security review of sensitive
issues that any author would have to be
subjected to before that information
could be published I work in a history
office really largely of academics and
fortunately we do have free reign pretty
much to interpret things as we want to
it with regard to our other books as
well as this one published by the Naval
Institute press what is that is that
connected with the government no they
want to do press as a private press and
in no way connected with the government
there absolutely is the
Oh official imprimatur fact we've
alienated as many of the members of the
military as we've as we've pleased with
this book we I think it's a good test of
the candor and the balance and the
objectivity of it is that some of the
POWs liked it some don't some of the
government officials think it's terrific
pee on to the success and performance of
the military and others think we were
too harsh
what would they a.m. what would the POWs
not like about the book one that
complain the ones that complain feel
that there are a couple inches where
they say we got a fact wrong a date
wrong although to an amazing extent most
of them say we could we nailed it right
on the head we got it right but there's
some who will say you know you didn't
get this exactly right there's some who
feel that we were maybe a little bit too
critical of the their individual
performance and give them enough credit
I don't want to betray any confidences
but there were were a couple who
believed that we were not not fair to
them we feel we were we feel the memoirs
sometimes a little too self-serving so
we were careful to use the memoirs
advisedly and to always base our
conclusions on the on the corroborated
statements and how many books have been
written by POWs probably about two dozen
good memoirs
many of them are superficial but there's
some excellent excellent ones out there
Alvarez as a memoir that's it's pretty
good the best one to my knowledge is
Jerry coffees memoir Denton has one
called when he'll was in session
Nick Rowe who is another
case of animal just escaped from the
South in Rose case as an excellent
memoir called five years to freedom
they're about two dozen of them out
there they're very few books about the
POWs very few books such as this which
deal with POWs of a non memoir type and
in any kind of a comprehensive way and
that deal with the South and Laos as
well is with with the north and with
civilians we also deal with about sixty
civilians who were captured their
sentences like this that jump out
throughout the entire book and I just
read it so you can explain how much of
this one on this is in the chapter on
Dirty Bird and Alcatraz a couple of
prison food consisted of pumpkin or
cabbage soup sometimes with a piece of
pig fat floating in it
the lack of protein and poor sanitation
left the PW is that's short for pow1
herbal to the usual infections parasites
and diarrhea typical was the incident
described in Rutledge's memoir where
Jenkins awoke one night with what he
thought was a piece of string in his
mouth that turned out to be a six-inch
worm right
they were routinely afflicted with
dysentery with with worms in the south
again even worse conditions because of
the lack of fruit and vegetables all
together very very scurvy type of
diseases in the north they did have at
least occasional access to even if it
was rotten some fruits and vegetables
pumpkin one new arrival came and was
delighted to see that there was actually
some rye bread on his plate until he
noticed that the seeds were starting to
move there was very very little in the
way of palatable food except during
holidays and and toward the end when
they were being fattened up so that at
the time of release they would would
look better and would reflect the
quality they so-called alleged humane
and lenient treatment that the
Vietnamese had maintained that they had
always extended to the peers that just
there you have a lot of pictures like
this where you
six former POWs and the fellow up there
in the left hand corner is Harlan
Chapman
I just noticed because you had 100
interviews he wasn't interviewed and it
led me to ask you whether or not some of
the POWs wouldn't be interviewed for
this or how did you pick the one well
Fred Kiley again did most of the
interviewing and he would know better
than I whether there were those who who
objected or rejected the opportunity to
be interviewed as far as I know there
was no one who turned down the
opportunity fred was trusted because he
was Air Force and had served in Vietnam
he had been an advisor there for the
Vietnamese Air Force in 1968-69 Kiley
knew a lot of the POWs in some ways Fred
and I had a certain there was a dynamic
and a certain tension between us where
fred was usually in some of these cases
where we were wondering how how
effective the guys were at resistance or
how staunch they were in their
resistance fred would be sort of going
to give the guy to benefit out I think I
brought some detachment to the process
of evaluating the POWs some academic
detachment so I think was a good balance
between Fred's insider knowledge of
these guys and my my detachment and I
think that helped us come up with a
pretty good balanced and objective view
of them
here's another line in the book and I
just I was taking these out of context I
couldn't quite put my finger on it but
the atmosphere was changing for the
worse by November for starters food
rations at the zoo were cut drastically
and kitchen staff were no longer washing
off the human fertilizer the Vietnamese
used for their crops a lot of reference
to human feces being in in rice you know
all over these cells how much explain
the human fertilizer business right well
it was a fact of life and in the South
in fact you know the conditions are the
food was so bad that oftentimes the the
Vietnamese themselves were eating this
this tainted stuff
the dent makes the point that at one
point one of the I think it's cat who is
the head of a prison system or the nice
prison system says do you know you're
eating [ __ ] and Denton's den who was as
tough as I come would say does it have
any protein in it somehow they adapted
they were able to do this they were able
to down this stuff and eat it with
problems with disease some of some of
them died from disease in fact most of
they're about 100 POWs who died during
the course of the captivity during the
course of a decade and most of them from
disease dysentery malaria very very food
problems and so for stomach problems
rather than from torture but yeah this
was this was the condition this was it
was the there was I'm trying to another
instance where in fact they would use
fertilizer for their own garden and they
would later eat the food they didn't
have access to clean water and
oftentimes no water at all so it was one
of the elements that they had to deal
with the names David Dellinger Tom
Hayden Jane Fonda Mary McCarthy others
the strike women strike for peace come
up when they visited over there
in retrospect from all these years what
impact did those people have on the
prisoners only over there when they
would go visit right well the impact
would would vary usually the when the
Dellinger's of the Hayden's would come
over there the prisoners on the one hand
would often be trotted out with trays of
cookies and a fairly nice circumstance
it might get a break in terms of some
decent food and a break from from the
monotony
but at the same time they were being
exploited for the purposes of showing
the humane and lenient side of the
Vietnamese and the Hayden's and the
others would go back to the United
States and say that these guys are being
treated fine there's no reason for
concern so it was a fact of them being
over there was to really enhance the
propaganda campaign of the North
Vietnamese and it angered the POWs
tremendously also when they would hear
Jane Fonda were hating on the radio
spouting about the American imperialists
and the Vietnamese being so humane and
lean the treatment of their prisoners
giving the wrong wrong impression
bruiser had a real problem with Mary
McCarthy and she was Louise Robinson
risen er who was the Air Force
lieutenant colonel and along with Denton
and Stockdale one of the leaders of the
POWs run the seniors senior ranking
officers rizz there's an interesting
case because he was exploited probably
as much as any of the senior officers he
would be trotted out for these
interviews with the visiting journalists
and he would be asked to tape on the
radio because he was well known he had
been the subject of a Time magazine
article he was an ace Korean War ace and
they exploited him mercilessly they even
would trot prisoner out for these early
release ceremonies where they would
release some of the POWs and he became a
part of the pageant and of course it
frustrated him greatly and he underwent
tremendous I think psychological
suffering as well as spending a lot of
time in solitary also doing portions of
his
captivity so risen er endured an awful
lot along with Stockdale and the other
other seniors ever Alvarez you mentioned
earlier who was the longest serving in
the North wrote things like this the
pain was excruciating they uh it felt
like a hacksaw had stuck deep in my
flesh the cuffs seemed to cut off to the
bone my head was pushed forward and all
I could do was yell and scream to write
out the pain they left me alone for
quarter-hour spells and then returned
yanking my arms up and squeezing the
cuffs tighter yet the worse had got the
latter I shrieked the more I hailed the
more they slapped in punts 2jc preferred
to strike from behind but when he came
from in front of it it was always the
underside of his closed fist my eyes
felt like popping my veins wanted to
explode in a gush of boiling blood JC
was joined by Ichabod Crane a spindly
six-two turnkey with a drooping head
blazing draconian eyes and clothes that
were too short and tight fitting
together they worked me over heartlessly
like a couple of kids pulling wings off
flies later on he says it would be two
years before they would regain their
natural color meaning his hands many
guys came out with injuries that never
healed back injuries leg injuries of
course all kinds of scars and other
other effects the the ratchet cuffs were
another very difficult thing for them to
handle along with the Rope torture
sometimes the the degree the severity of
the torture would be inadvertent the
Vietnamese didn't realize at at times
they were you were using small they were
used to they were using some cuffs and
manacles that had been used on
Vietnamese prisoners tended to be a lot
had smaller wrists and so these things
tended to be a lot of smaller dimension
and so the Americans even when these
things would be clamped on and were not
ratcheted that caused tremendous pain at
the Vietnamese and even realized so
using the manacles and shackles that
were often very construed
did to begin with because they were
downsized to originally to suit their
smaller the dimensions of the Vietnamese
prisoners created pain from the
beginning and then these things would be
ratcheted what it is
that's a picture of it's a matrix of
what was called the the tap code which
was the probably the primary form of
communication it's a five by five matrix
of the alphabet containing all the
letters except the letter K for which
they substituted the letter C and they
use this matrix and they could rotate
the letters in a way that in which they
were able to tap almost any kind of a
message often using an abbreviated form
for example one of the early sign offs
that appears in almost all the messages
which god bless you as they're talking
to messaging to one another and the G
would be in the second line ABCD efg
it's it's a second row and the second
vertical column so it would be a 2 to
the B would be would be 1/2 second row a
a first row across a second row down and
they got to the point where they could
do this with almost kind of a blinding
kind of a speed and they were able to
use a system of tapping either through
the wall or they could apply it as
dentin did - sneezes and coughs or even
sweeping with a broom back to the sneeze
it's a second because there you point
out in here that when they would sneeze
they would also say some rather strong
things signaling the entire camp that
what bad a sense of humor or there was a
lot of humor there's a lot of humor in
the book it's black humor often but they
were sustained by humor and they each
would have kind of a signature sneeze in
which they would you know get [ __ ]
you know or or you know or worse
obscenities in their sneezes it's some
strong things to say about Ho Chi Minh
right they would typically
garble the name hoochie Minh and it
would come out worship men one of their
real nemec's was an Australian
journalist named Wilfred ver shet
communist journalist who would was
writing pieces around the world about
how terrific the Vietnamese were and how
evil and T realistic the POWs in the
American military was and whenever they
would be forced to read on the radio I
mentioned Al bread know he was one of
those who would garble the sound of
Wilfred bruschetta he would come out
well-fed [ __ ] there was a lot of
that sort of thing Col Berg was nub he's
a Navy sure of burgers navy or Air Force
but he was noted for his humor and
oftentimes would entertain the other
POWs with various kinds of stick or
things that he would do there was a
guard who and one occasion a guard who
were and learned some English and an
English expression and so Carlberg
decided to teach him in English
expression he said whenever you get up
in the morning and you want to say hello
and he knew some Vietnamese he was
explaining that hello is on queer you
say I'm queer so this one guard was very
proud of this English Indian learn would
get up in the every morning for weeks
would go from cell to cell and say I'm
queer and we're so it was the kind of
hijinks the kind of light touch that
occasionally in between torture would
what would lighten the mood and and
sustain them over a period of time who
was tortured or don't have to be one
that the most though that they you know
we read just a little bit of this but
they went beyond what we've read well
probably the two worst torture cases
would be the
case of Edward at Edwin Atterbury
and the case of Kobe oh these are two
Air Force the OWS Atteberry made a
mistake of trying to escape with John
Jimmy see another Air Force Academy she
was Air Force Major this would have been
in 1969 spring of 1969 Atterbury and
Jimmy C had an elaborate escape plan a
good plan actually although no one ended
up successfully escaping from the north
you could escape from the prison maybe
but they would would usually be able to
find you enter a short while and and
Atterbury injure me see were captured
soon after getting out of the zoo annex
in a spring of 69 which turned out to be
a terrible thing for the other prisoners
who took tremendous punishment
retaliation but the worst case was
Atteberry who was put in a torture cell
and I would say in the book description
of the of what he underwent the shrieks
that were heard from both the equivalent
of blocks several block city blocks away
and he died in that torture cell one of
the very few cases where a man was
tortured to death and that was in direct
retaliation for that escape ever Jimmy
see also took terrible punishment but
survived and some of the other POWs took
to golf a punishment Jeanne McDaniel
read McDaniel took seven hundred lashes
there was even some electroshock
treatment that which is usually resort
to this is the same read McDaniel that
we have seen since then very active in
yes whoo rudders continues to be very
active on the MIAA and the powa ship
McDaniel took tremendous punishment
because he was a senior in the zoo area
in that complex and the POWs assume that
all this had been orchestrated at the
germ easy Atterbury escape had been
organized and directed by the seniors
which really wasn't the case
Jimmy's he pretty much went on his own
and although he finally got the order
that it was okay to go there was a lot
of reluctance on the part of actually
was Conrad Troutman you mentioned
earlier he was a senior who said okay
you want to try and go ahead but there
would always be the concern that if a
guy didn't make it or for that matter
even if he did make it the repercussions
for the guys that were left left behind
he would be punished in Italian for that
the other case came true and it came
true there would every camp for for two
months there was a it was probably the
worst sustained torture period would
have been in the spring and summer of 69
at every one of the camps in the north
and again there were four or five main
prison so not only the zoo and the zoo
annex but at at wallah enoy Hilton at
the plantation
Asante and all the other camps in the
north the other case the severe torture
case would have been a real code vo who
was a victim it was called the Cuban
program down the Fidel program yeah
Fidel wasn't explained who he was okay
well we still don't know exactly who
Fidel was it's on the remaining
mysteries of the POWs story we think
that Fidel was a Cuban a Spaniard of
some type probably Cuban from his
appearance from the language shows up
one day along with a entourage of a few
other Cubans some of them came a little
bit later showed up at the zoo in this
would have been in 1967-68 somewhere in
there Fidel shows up rather suddenly and
he's given all kinds of special
deferential treatment by the Vietnamese
it's hard to tell whether he is a
supported or communist superior to the
Vietnamese or the Vietnamese are just
indulging this foreign visitor he's
given kind of free rein for about two
months actually the Cuban program would
extend almost almost
of course of a year with about 20 POWs
two groups of ten each who were taken
out of the zoo annex and put in a
special part of the compound and Fidel
was able to it's hard to know exactly
what the purpose of the program was it
appears that it was a program that kind
of turnout Manchurian candidates for
early release to punish guys so severely
and indoctrinate them to the extent that
they could be prepped for early release
and then would just be just recite the
Vietnamese the Communist line when they
got out we're not sure exactly again we
don't know the details of this program
because no one's ever determined Fidel's
identity or the Cubans identity because
they left after a year and dia analysts
have been trying to track this guy for
years trying to locate him all we know
is that several of the POWs in this
program in particular code Beal were
viciously tortured and kind of an
alternation of carrot-and-stick over a
period of time Co Beals mistake
this is Earl Coby only Air Force Major I
believe was to be in bad shape to begin
with and Fidel assumed that he was the
co bo was faking insanity and he said
we've got a faker here and he just
continued to beat the hell out of the
guy in session after session until the
co Beale was mindless was just
completely numb didn't know where he was
who he was could not eat he had to be
force-fed by some of the others at the
zoo and he would die sometime later
about a year or two later from what was
one of the severus torture episodes you
say that the average age of the 800 was
39 that their rank was o4 meaning major
or lieutenant commander that they were
fathers of three children on average
they spent 45 months in confinement and
six to 12 months in solitary confinement
but what was the solitary confinement
like
and who served the longest in solitary
all right well solitary was the worst
kind of solitary with darkness and a
small cell often with vermin and rats
and things that you could hear but could
not see occasionally you might be let
out for a half hour a day the only break
would be get a receiving the food
usually two meals a day around ten
o'clock and 3 o'clock the longest that
were held in solitary would have been
probably the seniors Denton Stockdale
and risen er Ben Purcell who was an Army
Major in the South spent a long time in
solitary
Ernie brace a civilian captured in Laos
also spent a long time in solitary
solitary required as much as anything
obviously a bility to cope to distract
yourself to kill time to not to run some
way to survive what red McDaniel called
the inner the inner struggle the mental
struggle that all the POWs really had to
go through torture occurred fairly
regularly but there were long periods in
between where the real challenge was to
just to mentally stay together and
survive just the monotony of the routine
and the boredom and particularly in
solitary you used that time in solitary
either to restore yourself physically by
just kind of walking and pacing back and
forth it was on the cover a good
question I don't know this is the cover
that the Naval Institute press chose to
use it is a photograph or a rendering of
a photograph that appeared at the an
exhibit at the Capitol and Capitol
building and believed in 1970 at Ross
Perot organized and I am not sure myself
who that is
it is a worst-case scenario of obviously
the prisoner who had undergone
tremendous punishment and malnutrition
what is this book cost book cost $36
50 Cent's Emily 700 pages lots of
illustrations 50 pages of documentation
and a good read as well as we think a an
expert analysis where is this photograph
from that's a photograph of the POWs on
one of the aircraft finally taking off
from from Hanoi in probably February or
March 1973 they were stoic almost up to
that point they were told not to show
any emotion until they got on the plane
not to give the Vietnamese any any
satisfaction and they were also pretty
enervated by that time but that's a
group that finally when they realized
they were leaving captivity some of them
perhaps after seven or eight years just
let it all out and in an absolute joy
and elation you say in the book that the
returnee debriefings have been kept
confidential did you see them and did
you use any of that information in the
book yeah we we did see the debris
things not all of them but but many of
them we could not quote directly from
them even in paraphrasing we had to be
very careful what we used but we the
real value of the debris things was in
just kind of informing us and giving us
a sense of what a Stockdale or arisen er
had experienced so that we could better
judge their memoirs and the published
literature but the the briefings are
considered confidential and we respected
that confidence as well as even other
POWs who want to see others to briefings
are not really allowed to get to get to
use those Senator John McCain what kind
of a prisoner was he McCain was uh
unquestionably a
the hard resistor hardline courageous
tremendous fortitude just to have
survived his initial injuries on his
shoot down McCain landed up in landed in
prison landed in Hanoi after a shoot
down and his probably bad a condition as
any prisoner who survived a crash or
shoot down a bail out he had a bad back
he had broken legs arms would be in cast
for much of his captivity in fact he
almost drowned in fact on landing in
Hanoi landed in a lake in the city and
with his equipment on somehow despite
his injuries got out of the leg ended up
at the plantation and would resist
indoctrination and resisted
interrogation the vietnamese knew that
he was the son of an admiral admiral
mccain's pacific they knew they had a
prize they tried desperately to get him
to tape or to write something that they
could use for propaganda purposes he
refused he was punished repeatedly
somehow recovered from his injuries with
the help of a couple cellmates who
nursed him along and would become one of
the leaders in the resistance and last
question to you where did you get the
time honorbound we decided on honorbound
just because it had
I captured both concepts of the
captivity there being bound but also the
importance of honor that was the key
thing to retain your honor to observe
the code of conduct and as the the their
symbolic phrase was to return with honor
to Rochester along with them
your co-author Frederick County thank
you very much for joining us thank you
for having me